what character storyline in season three
most looking forward to i'm looking
forward to robert's surprise
um i suppose it really depends what you
know if you if you've been in season
three which uh
um bring the ice i i wasn't this it
depends if you've read the books and if
you know from your friends what's
happening with that character but from
from having watched the first
first two episodes of this season um i
think
um looking at it i was kind of um i felt
the most sense of distress and kind of
sympathy for um
oh goodness me i'm so sorry stannis
is right hand man help me think anyone
oh yeah
everyone yeah i felt some kind of a huge
amount of sympathy for him because um
partially because in relation to my
character i'm basically watching his son
being burnt to a crisp in the ocean and
so you kind of feel sorry for him but uh
i want to kind of know
why it is that someone sort of helped a
situation where he
would they would even bother to kind of
focus on you just would assume you would
dissipate into nothing if you suffered
so much so he interests me within the
series
yeah for me it's the hound but i kind of
understood where he screamed and i'm
kind of like what is that about
but i love the dragons i love all about
the dragons
double double branded theory of my top
three because um
masculine you know she's she's kind of
very very
strong not a girly girl of any stretch
and yet she's kind of got all the men
that work for her by the balls
so
yes
a great character to play because she's
got such a strong sense of self and
what's rightfully hairs and how she
feels that her trajectory should
play out is firm in her mind so whatever
she has to do to do that is
fun to play and i suppose yeah
it's regardless of whether she's female
or not i think she doesn't really
care so much about gender as long as
she's in control
you know
what was that
lots of characters are like really good
characters but really poor role models
um is there any characters that you
think that people that like you would
find yourself inspiring them to be more
like or are they all just horrible nasty
people
the best of the characters is probably
ned style so
question because um
nothing to do with being world house
lannister but i would honestly say
tyrion here's my reason um even though
even though you find him to be a kite he
is obviously very uh you know cunning
and
sometimes fairly malicious as i'm fully
aware in his tactics and sometimes i
what i do really like about him uh is
that he
he's very good at being bad
in it for the sake of aspiring to be
good because he's aware he has to kind
of he has to kind of obviously never
play their game thrones with people who
are who are just incredibly well
insecure such as cersei and i i like the
idea that he's doing it for the sake of
simply wanting to actually make it
better you know he wants to stop all
these people who are who were rioting
and ever in
flea bottom sort of suffering so um
i like that the controversy of that
being bad for the sake of trying to be
good
i read something about the writers
talking about how they wrote that
character they wrote him as if he was
from a different age everyone else is
sort of medieval
are you going to be doing any cartoon
series or musicals this christmas we
could incorporate all those funny
youtube clips of people using animals to
create the game of thrones soundtrack
yes
which of the cast members do you really
enjoy working with
all of them
if they're all brilliant
that's good
i hate them all
sam and hannah um and they're both
brilliant uh had a great time working
with them this year and last year so
there's a little indication of what i'm
gonna be working with this year
yeah
i think i think
i've enjoyed doing um doing my my
i i call it the groveling scene in
season two i did enjoy doing that with
peter that was a lot of fun that was um
but um
funnily enough i was talking today about
when i was doing my scene with that with
here and mark when i was walking through
the woods trying to offer more wine and
for some reason i had a huge amount of
fun in that because they didn't notice
but it was incredibly difficult to keep
up the mark
i know
and i had my cape and i literally just
couldn't keep up but i had a lot of fun
doing that scene that was when i kind of
got very um
very into it so i would say uh
it would be uh again my top three
probably peter
which
doesn't appear in the uh in the books
really but in order to give
uh
audience unfamiliar with the books a bit
of history as to who they are and what
they're about and uh it was like a it
was a sort of seven page scene that they
threw it was the night before
after you've been to the forest come
back and shoot this
oh
um god it's the only time that robert
and cersei speak so that was
that was a it was a joy of working with
lena on that
uh and seeing you know that
there was there was really no hope for
them
um all the castle gamer phones are so
lovely there's not like one
bad
actor
but um when i was on set at the class
was back um i
enjoyed mostly hanging around with um
johnny play sam uh yeah one's a bit too
quiet
there's
a personal library of admirer charles
dance
theater for many many years but the
system get together
was like standing in a head master's
office
such a lovely guy
um i've only worked with patrick and
alfie really in terms of uh on set
but like you guys said the one you've
come across after or before in the hotel
when you opened shootings
certainly patrick was something else to
work with because he's so
his sense of humor is so dry
and then and he would just have a lot of
fun together but then it would be very
very serious when we were doing her
scenes so yeah
those two are
magnificent
um so many people from um
around the castle formerly known as
vanderbilt um
i have to say isaac um isaac and i are
very close um he's such a talented kid
you know and that was my first proper
acting job at sodor
and then i remember my first day um was
the same with peter jenkins and richard
modern and i was literally the first
time i walked on this set and that was
an emmy award winner and
it's kind of intended but it's a really
good place to learn
um i'm working with people like um
donald softer who's like immensely
talented british actor and i've learned
so much from him
um but yeah even from the kids that the
kids are so talented
and
obviously i've worked with isaac the
most
but
yeah hopefully hopefully it comes apart
from on screen but i really do love the
kid
you know
um
you're never on like a tarmac road
are you ever tempted to read the books
to find out what happens to your
characters or do you prefer the mystery
of not knowing what horrible thing will
happen to you next
to my character
is that a question about reading the
books
uh you wouldn't necessarily know this
but i'm one of those killed off actors
you ever met
i hate to ask too deeply the reasons why
um but uh
whenever i heard i was in this i didn't
even know it was based in a series of
books
i thought well perhaps i should read
them if only to find out because i mean
everybody's getting killed so i thought
a bit of people need to find out how
long i survived
and literally
half an hour in
couldn't put them down
and
i've read all the books that have so far
been published so i know the story best
actually from the books
uh and they're great
and the scale of his imagination is just
it's a job smacking i mean when you
think of somebody sitting down and
trying to you know just envisage this
whole world and all these characters and
how they interconnect it's the most
extraordinary piece of imagination
it's quite brilliant and i also think
the way that it's been condensed
by the writing team for the series is
also quite critical you know so the
writing on both props is
you know
you can't fault it
i think i think it depends kind of what
kind of person you are literally if you
choose to read but funnily enough
actually it was it was ian reading on
set that made me think i actually really
wanted to carry on reading them but i
you know i i i read my i read all the
books um before i think just just before
i did my last c on season one and it was
because um
very kindly george emailed me and one
told me sort of roughly the the
something you may know the spiral that
that lancer undergoes and i thought that
in this particular occasion it would be
beneficial for me to know where he
starts
in contrast to where exactly he goes and
after the fifth book ends
and having read them i i
i played the or tried to play the first
two
seasons in such a way that the contrast
to what he changes and becomes would be
more hopefully hopefully enjoyable for
for the audience um but then again
charles for example charles dance i
think said very publicly that he didn't
want it he wanted to make it in his in
his sort of own image i mean he's done
as you all know a fantastic job so it's
it's all just comes down to a personal
choice really
i found that i found the book very
useful
in that
your entire character history is there
if you want it so wrong
creative backstory
he gives you all the reasons why you are
the way you are so
it was a i found it a really useful uh
tool
i haven't read none of the books
just for the main factors i'm quite
dyslexic that's why
i can't read the books they're too big
and just really hard to grasp um
i find it better when um
you listen to it on the cassettes then
reading the books um
so yeah
um
yeah um i wish i could read the books
because um
i would love to know your journeys of
yeah obviously my character
so um
and between the station and the hotel he
ruined all the books
of course this happened
about the books than i did and um
i thought it would be more fun because
no one really knows who google is really
they don't know why it is the way it is
and i kind of felt a bit more fun just
to do it my way
rather than
sort of try and pull something out of
pages
so i thought i would try and make it up
for myself and that's why i didn't
lesson two
um i didn't want to hear him say hodor i
didn't want to hear anything i just
wanted to do it my way
so
who'd win a fight between hodor and the
mountain with no weapons just fists
at some point so this is looking quite
really
who's your favorite character and why
i would say tyrion um just
because of
his
philosophy on on life and survival i
think it's admirable
he plays the game well
i was always in front of you
i just thought it was a really um really
kind of cool uh
nice interesting character that could
have been um rather like that i forget
his name but rather like that character
john snow hanging out with before his
wolf
eats him brutally um there are all these
kind of really hard hard characters that
kind of just just died for the sake of
um
of the the betterment of the moment
basically and so i just thought he was
really cool character really
um he's stuck in my head quite a lot
mother of the dragons
you're upset
went into the fire and came out with two
dragons on her shoulder it's just so
awesome three yes
um
yeah
that's that's my thing
there are so many
fantastic characters very hard to choose
i really like uh
i'm fascinated to know what will happen
with samuel
uh
um
yeah just so many yeah good characters
this and there's more so
you know
the
my favorite character by a long shot in
many ways he's just so duplicitous and
it's so well played
and a different choice from
that i could have said or something
yeah
um
there's different parts of each
character i like um
yeah i wasn't a huge fan of calisi i
always i like the story lines and stuff
and obviously it is amazing but um until
the last episode um clicking behind your
knife
as soon as you got that bottom of your
there's something really stupid to me
that you said like um
obviously he's a dwarf and um
take the thing that's different about
yourself and use it like an armor
i mean that makes sense you know i mean
that's stuff you could apply to your
real life is a wise job so he'll be
definitely one of my favorite characters
also
i've heard stories through gemma about
the times he's had with alfie on
horseback and i've heard stories
i'd have heard stories from christian
about broken iphones and prosthetic
willies
i'd like to know from the rest of the
cast do you have any stories about props
or animals that you've had to work with
on the show
i
have never
ridden a horse in my life until i worked
on game of thrones i mean i've been on a
horse once in a dude ranch out in
the middle of somewhere when i was 10
on a very slow nag
but i
arrived
for my horse training in january with
the devil's horseman
um then i got on a you know 16-hand
horse is huge
and uh i loved it i thought it was
fantastic i came back the next day and i
said oh the studio filmed uh you can't
use a saddle you're riding bareback
so
for me
mastering that was just incredible and i
got very used to this wonderful horse
called spiky beautiful white horse
and of course on the day when i came in
to shoot they said that we decided to go
with a completely different horse
so i've worked for two months with this
one horse and they changed it over to
this really amazing stallion uh black
gorgeous horse uh but he was not
um he didn't take to me quite so much so
it was a battle of wills and
balance and i had a great time had a
really amazing shoot with him but he
challenged me and that was fantastic
the the armorer as you would imagine on
phones was was fantastic and i had i was
really kind of excited when i was given
for the season two my uh
my sword not only because i'm a boy and
it's a sword but because it was um
it was the the the pommel of it was uh
was the uh the lion of lannister and i
said oh that's very nice that's great
well done it looks like it's almost real
and he said well the thing is that we
base the sword on the design of tywin
lannister and i said what this is this
is this is game of thrones vintage
and i went
right
i want to keep this may i keep this
and that was my my favorite prop if you
like if you see me every time i'm just
never letting go
i hold on to it like it's my own so that
was my um
that was my kind of fond adventure
king's landing i mean they look
fantastic but i'll tell you they're
writing a nightmare when they're trying
to go to the moon
and they all start bending in the middle
and then they won't flatten down so you
suddenly find you're getting pricked by
something
horse training yet um because i haven't
read the horse and gave my phones yet
there was one scene where we um
catch
uh jon snow and uh you see me riding
horseback
so i haven't ridden any horses
uh what else um costumes yeah it's just
just going to the toilet you'll
get yourself done and
you can tie a few stuff and you have to
ask a few people to tie you you can't
get to the back and that's the only time
you want to go taller
it gives you
these cloaks which were
quite regal and trailed along the floor
by about
two feet
once once it's rained and you're walking
with this thing behind you the bottom
half of it is
um
the blood as well was a real pain i
remember we were doing the black water
scene we were all just sitting in the
green room and we were just about four
in the morning and we were all just
and he said right right guys we gotta go
and everyone oh god okay and look at the
blood that was basically jam
and everyone got up and i'm not kidding
most people went
and draw their chair either with them or
slip across the room and i think i think
it was it was me that got up and didn't
notice
literally couldn't tell i had a chair
attached to me
yeah series three i was working with a
lot of fake snow as well which you'll
see uh
and
when i opened my mouth i was like
last year
anything that [ __ ] is easy to pull as i
march in looking all strong
as because he's um obviously
patrick has taken off the ball saying
that he's paid the iron or gold price
and then closes on the floor and then i
come in but i had to walk straight past
and over the cloak and we did take off
the tape because i've been coming in
okay so eventually they had to get a
little pops guys to pull it out of the
way because i couldn't stop looking over
it
using my car
yeah
um
it has a little sack
and somewhere so i've got it
um but um basically whenever you see
that on camera there's probably an
iphone
um from the rest of the class as well
but that's really cool
yes it was prosthetic but i did not have
a fortunate attack
voice
my dressing room
in the bush
ah
i badly want to stab joffrey in the face
if you could stab any of the characters
in the face who would you stab and why
which character would you slap in the
face
um
is great the one that you feel actually
deserves something something bad to
happen to them
keeps on hanging in there and you're not
wondering where they're ever going to go
you know
whereas you know you get something over
like the head start and you think you
want to solve
for my mom it's so good
i'm always i was always a great person
to say you know people are so horrible
jack he's a great actor and he'll get
some flat foot and i watched the dark
knight or the first batman club he had a
small role i not available
oh
kathleen stark's sister drove me bonkers
she drove me absolutely mad in in the
the books and also his fantastic world
performance series but um i think it's
because i sort of know someone like her
and i i just i couldn't stand the the
sort of the utter insanity of the woman
so uh she she's definitely irritated
she does
you've got with your brother on
horseback and you with your cousin how
do you deal with those scenes in your
head knowing sort of technically what
you're meant to be portraying
so i have an awkward series with
ancestors yeah
what was
um
but yeah i suppose it's just part of the
job it's just you kind of
although my audition i didn't really
understand what was happening because it
was um written as two different
characters so she was called ezra the
nation was called yara
but i was up for
the reading both parts so i thought
maybe i'm not two parts something else
down until i got in the room and he
explained i was like
oh
and then he said if you can just imagine
that now and go now
doesn't come naturally but it's much
easier because everyone's kind of cool
so
i think i think
i don't know about everyone else but
when you know that you're going to be
doing an intimate scene they usually
give you some sort of uh
warning probably the right word in
advance
when you when you first get the job but
my my
particular thing with um with lena what
we had to do with my new scene well it
was incredibly um odd because i hadn't
met lena until that day
and not only had i not met her but i
came on to set with my wearing my
dressing gown and keeping you underneath
and she
lined up with me coming out of our
caravans and i went ah hello
and then he did the same thing and then
her mother appeared
but i think i think again
on the day you just you've all sort of
known exactly what's of going to happen
and yeah finally nervous but it once
once once it goes off and kills her off
and it's just about the scene really um
so i suppose it's sort of
it's sort of like the real thing
i have a question to anyone who's read
the book um but in particular ian your
character barristan selmy met daenerys
targaryen very differently in the book
to the way she did in the series
um do you feel that anything was missed
out do you feel any of your characters
should have had something from the book
added to the series or the other way
around
well uh
for those who know the book i have to
say i really liked the character of fat
bell was
in fact
uh so in some ways you know
having it would have been nice to have
had a bit of a journey with that
character you know
and and probably get to know uh
daenerys more slowly than than
transpires in this particular version of
it but there you go that's the way it is
it has to be condensed in some way
i also rather fancy the idea of leaving
a staff
which uh you know what happens in the
book it doesn't happen in this
uh but
you know
you've obviously got to condense these
things and it was very
well condensed and uh it does what is
necessary it gets the character back
into the story in a
in quite a dramatic sort of way and
and leaves the door open for what comes
after you know so
you know
that's the kind of thing where sometimes
knowing the book is probably not an
advantage because
there is a danger you kind of miss
something
but you've got to put it on your head
and just say i i do what is in front of
me and that's all i can do and that's
all i should be thinking about
brilliant well unfortunately we're gonna
have to
wrap it up there so uh thanks to the
classification
you